has visto letreros como estos y no sabes
qué significan no te preocupes
nos pasa a todos todo el tiempo las
personas que escriben los letreros lo
hacen pensando en poner mucha
información en poco espacio
entonces usan símbolos códigos o
palabras que parecen estar en clave y
aunque ellos creen que los clientes van
a entender el anuncio la verdad es que a
veces son un poco confusos por ejemplo
si ves este letrero que es lo primero
que se te viene a la mente
una multiplicación una fecha una oferta
nada puede tener muchos significados
dependiendo del lugar en el que se
encuentre
primero hay que aclarar que el letrero
dice hoy 2 x 1 no se refiere a la
multiplicación porque no tiene caso
escribir que sólo hoy multiplicamos 2
por 1 quiere decir que hoy nos van a dar
2 productos por el precio de uno el
signo de x se utiliza para decir cuánto
nos vamos a llevar por cierta cantidad
entonces si ves este anuncio en el
puesto de globos significa que hoy hay
una oferta en donde compramos dos y sólo
pagamos uno lo primero que nos va a
decir el anuncio es el tipo de
información y en qué contexto está es
decir el lugar en donde lo estamos
viendo vamos a interpretar el siguiente
letrero no te espantes lo haremos juntos
solo hay que entender la información con
otros datos que conozcamos el letrero
está en una ferretería por lo tanto debe
ser alguna cinta adherible para
reparaciones porque otras cintas que
conozco son de tela y no las venderían
en una ferretería
puede ser una cinta para coche pero no
es una tienda de refacciones así que
podría ser una cinta de aislar una cinta
adhesiva o una cinta para empacar el dos
coladas l segunda como hay algunos
productos que tienen distintos tipos de
calidad a veces depende de la marca o
del material con el que están hechos
esta cinta es de segunda calidad el 30
el 10 y el 3 de ser metros centímetros o
decímetros y está bien solo hay que
fijarnos un poco para saber a qué se
refiere aquí tenemos otra vez el signo
de x sin indicar una multiplicación
precisamente nos indica tres medidas
especificando largo ancho y profundidad
o grosor empecemos con el 30
generalmente las cintas se venden por
rollos de muchos metros el 30 puede
representar los metros de largo de la
cinta si fueran 30 centímetros de largo
sería demasiado corta y si fueran 30
centímetros de ancho sería demasiado
ancha y grande así que dejemos el 30
para metros a lo largo
ahora el 10 no pueden ser metros porque
nos falta el ancho y el grosor de la
cinta para el grosor 10 centímetros es
mucho no podría enrollarse y 10
milímetros sería igual a un centímetro
no tiene caso poner 10 milímetros si
pudieron haber puesto un centímetro
dejemos el 10 como centímetros y que sea
el ancho de la cinta
solo nos falta el 3 y la única medida
faltante sería el grosor de la cinta
tres centímetros sería para una cinta
demasiado gruesa y no se podría doblar
así que con tres milímetros tendremos
una medida adecuada ya descubrimos a qué
se referían estos números ahora nos
falta una parte del letrero que
seguramente ya sabes qué significa esta
parte se lee 25 por ciento de descuento
y significa que la cinta cuesta 25%
menos que su precio original es decir
ésta más barata por eso han puesto la
información en un letrero para que la
gente se entere de la oferta y por
último el renglón de abajo nos informa
que el precio anterior era de 124 pesos
espera hay otro signo de port pero en
esta ocasión no representa una medida
sino que indica que el precio es por 12
piezas o sea 12 cintas super logramos
averiguar que estas cintas se venden por
paquetes o cajas que incluyen 12 piezas
es por eso que las venden en la
ferretería para que las personas que se
dedican a hacer reparaciones compren por
paquete
si el letrero se escribiera con toda la
información que desciframos diría oferta
cinta de segunda calidad de 30 metros de
largo 10 centímetros de ancho y 3
milímetros de grosor con un 25% de
descuento antes el paquete de 12 cintas
costaba 124 pesos es mucho para el
letrero que quieren que se lea
rápidamente acertijo resuelto al
principio parecía que era complicado de
entender pero ya viste que no lo es solo
es cuestión de poner atención e ir
entendiendo cada elemento del mensaje
hay muchas formas de escribir
información con símbolos matemáticos que
irás conociendo poco a poco presta
atención a tu alrededor y no dejes que
te sorprenda otro ser dijo mientras
estás distraído